Marvel just came out with a new trailer
for Avengers infinity war and it is
amazing it's full of information so
let's go ahead and just jump right into
it before we get started please be sure
to subscribe to my channel to stay
up-to-date on Avengers infinity war the
entire time I knew him he only ever had
one call
[Music]
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again
Santos the trailer starts off with
Gamora talking about Thanos gamora's
parents were killed by Thanos and when
danos killed her parents he actually
took her as his adopted daughter and
raised her unto a fighting machine
in the first Avengers we find out her
backstory and how she betrays Thanos and
is now an Avenger here they're trying to
get you to understand how powerful fan
OHS actually is and that he is the mad
Titan and wants to wipe out half of the
universe now what we see here that isn't
a testament to his power is that he is
actually holding an infinity stone with
his bare hands we see here when he puts
it in his gauntlet he's holding it in
his fingertips
this means that Thanos is crazy powerful
because we know that no mortal or any
regular person or being out there it can
hold an infinity stone and live here we
see fan OSes armor for the first time
which is really cool to see on screen we
haven't seen it in any of the movies yet
any trailers or any after the credits
scenes before we get into the next scene
I want to take a second here to look at
Iron Man's new bleeding-edge armor suit
and the nanotechnology that is in it
allowing the suit to basically turn into
anything that Tony Stark's desires here
we see it turning into a huge rocket to
propel him into deep space
we have with Danis once so that's what
we use
so what Tony is saying here is very
important because he's saying we have
what Danis wants and what he wants is
the Infinity stones then they show the
time stone that dr. strange has and the
mind stone that is envisioned for head
and then interestingly enough they cut
to what Conda it has been rumoured that
the soul stone is in Wakanda so this may
be a little bit of foreshadowing here
let's talk about this plant ears I think
it's good except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good Wow then we have this super awesome
scene where the guardians of the galaxy
meet and team up with Tony Stark and
spider-man for the first time we've
never seen this on screen I've been
waiting for it for a long time and I'm
just super excited to see this in the
movie in the next handful of seconds we
have clips of some of the Avengers and
Wakanda preparing to battle Thanos and
then there's this scene with Thor which
is very interesting to me this looks
like it's Nadal lair Nadav lair is where
Thor's original hammer Mjolnir was made
we know that Thor needs a new hammer to
battle Thanos and we know that he makes
Stormbreaker but what's interesting is
that it seems like nobody's there
this leads me to believe that Thanos got
there first and wiped everybody out Thor
seems to be using as lightning to power
everything back up so we can make
Stormbreaker himself this next scene is
actually pretty cool we see a flashback
by either Thanos or Gamora with Thanos
and baby Gamora in it perhaps we'll
learn more about gamora's childhood and
Thanos raising her this very brief clip
right here I think is where Thanos finds
Thor's ship with all the Asgardians on
it he destroys the ship and which is
where the guardians of the galaxy pick
up Thor in deep space this scene is
important here we have Loki in the
presence of the black order the black
order is Stannis's personal minions his
right-hand people and here we clearly
see that he's giving the tesseract to
Thanos then we see that us break the
tesseract to get the space stone out of
it good ol Loki causing trouble for the
Avengers again and trying to get on to a
nose his good side these clips right
here are pretty cool because we see
Captain America's new shield and we see
some of the nanotechnology and black
panther suit this scene right here is
awesome because we have Doctor
helping out star-lord on Titan trying to
fight famous then we have dr. strange
like appeared to be captured by evany
moth
I'm curious to see how this plays out
this next scene is Stannis apparently
telling Iron Man I hope they remember
you
Iron Man's suit looks just completely
destroyed he obviously just fought
Thanos and this could be where Iron Man
dies we'll have to see in the movie
this right here is really interesting to
me we see that us going to get Captain
but it looks like Captain is able to
resist him a little bit we can tell in
Thanos his face that he's a little bit
confused about how strong Captain
America is we all know he has a really
big heart but I don't think it's gonna
be enough to fight Thanos then we have
this final scene here with spider-man
and Doctor Strange but they meet and
then it cuts to spider-man on Titan and
it looks to me like vanos just through
the moon at Titan and there's the breeze
and meteors falling at Titan and it just
seems like spider-man's trying to not
die at this point there you have it the
New Avengers infinity war trailer we've
been waiting for it's so awesome it
makes me so excited to see the movie
just next month what did you guys think
let me know in the comments below be
sure to drop a like and please be sure
to subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on everything Avengers infinity war
Marvel and all things superhero thank
you so much for watching guys
have a great day